it is a problem all across our valley
that just is not going to go away
even with the eviction moratorium in
place our neighbors are losing their
homes and they have nowhere to go
the i-team's david charns is live near
downtown with one woman's heartbreaking
story david
well denise she thought she would one
day own the home she's renting in this
area but
then she was told she had defaulted on
those payments
and of course now with the pandemic
she's unable to pay rent
and her landlord is looking to sell
it's just been this last year has taken
its
toll with no job and weeks left to find
a new place to live
tina who didn't want to reveal her last
name is like thousands across the valley
there's no money coming in to pay rent
and nowhere to go
he called me monday and told me
that the house has been sold
and we have 18 days
to move tina was working to buy the home
she lives in with her daughter and dogs
but was told
last month she defaulted on payments
from several years ago
she's been paying rent on top of those
payments but without a job
she was unable to pay her november and
december rent
which is pretty good
for not being able to pay bills the
i-team found evictions
are down since the governor extended the
moratorium through the end of march
but they are happening in henderson 330
new filings in december in the first two
weeks of january
in north las vegas 403 and in las vegas
and the rest of the valley
more than 2 800. what may not have been
a crisis three months ago
now may be a real crisis jim burchtold
is the directing attorney at the legal
aid center of southern nevada
i hear the numbers that employment is
coming back
and jobs are coming back but it doesn't
feel that way on the ground when you're
talking to tenants
who are crying because they're being
evicted and have no place to go with the
street
documents show tina's landlord offered
up a payment plan for the two thousand
dollars she owes
but now they want to sell to avoid
bankruptcy
it's a tough situation for both parties
susie vasquez is the executive director
of the nevada state department
association
representing the owners of more than 140
000 rental units across the valley
we're not in the business of evicting
people we certainly want to keep our
units
full so we have been opening up payment
arrangements and
tenants have been really really great
i'm here for an immediate addiction
she stresses nine out of ten times that
happens but if a tenant refuses to
communicate or doesn't apply for
assistance
eviction can be an option and at the end
of the day all that back rent must be
paid
moratorium is not a rent waiver
by any stretch of the imagination for
tina the clock is ticking to move out of
the home she thought she would own one
day
a dream the pandemic shattered there's
no way
my daughter and i are going to be able
to move out of this house
10 years of our life is here
so this is the form the declaration you
can fill out if you need help
if you face eviction and you need help
it's called the declaration
it is also on our website a newsnow.com
now remember you have to give
your landlord a copy keep a copy for
yourself
and there's also many resources if you
need help to pay your rent during this
difficult time and we've reported
there are programs in federal money
coming into the county to help you with
that
it's a lot of information we got it all
for you right now on eightnewsnow.com a
copy of this as well
inside our app live near washington and
maine tonight i'm david charns 8 news
now